[Music]
isn't this bizarre at comic-con when you
travel around in this roving pack of
people you know you never at any other
time do this but what is it like to be
together and hang your comic-con how
much fun are you have it's not did I
know these people any other one they
search like family isn't this is I get a
higher than family Happy Thanksgiving
you're crazy I people comes and you're
like okay but who has their family down
here it is having fun and letting the
kids hang in your kids were just in here
by the way laughs where they stopped
they're so into it Eddy and yes
making people tell stories they they
were in here having a good time they
were part of our interview
really
okay like no work your kids are your
kids across on are you kids here hang on
cut one of my one of my kids is here is
the kid me like this really you know my
girls are across the street nerding out
as are they yeah they're God's played up
they were named cosplay for two days
it's like we're not taking it so yeah
Wow how is it been bringing this back to
a new generation because there are
people who have watched to impeach but
they don't really know too in pieces
they don't remember the phenomenon it
was the first time it came out so how is
it the second time around it's always
awesome there's a whole new fan base and
we have the old fan base as well and
many of the older ones have exposed to
their kids for better or for worse but
it's really it's exciting and it's also
just the fact that David Lynch is in
charge of everything so this is his baby
and
it's it's been an incredible ride you
know the times change and what you did
in the first 20 is you know it was
ground breaking down but now you've got
to amp it up because people imitate and
they they try to do what you've done so
how are you gonna amp up or change
things to make it even quicker as
shocking as one for camera guard Tim I
really enjoy I figured that would do it
that they wouldn't try it right doesn't
I mean we take quirky it's like he's
trying is not trying to make something
strange it just is and here's another
one yeah is it what what is that world
like was it like stepping into that I
think it's it's definitely always
guaranteed fund and you go there because
his vision is so clear and you trust him
because of not just because his body of
work but who he is
it is so convincing and it's always
despite how bizarre and surreal it is
it's always grounded in truth were there
times though when the e said cut you're
like did I really just do that yeah many
remember that scene in particular how is
it being back together in anybody great
is nothing back together is my one word
I can't one James oh that's great great
your family like a family who even I've
never met no I have some new members
that dodgy coming who knew who was the
new member that you were kind of like
okay alright they're really going to fit
into the team and who was the new memory
like we got it well we know who the new
member was at yellow that's 230 yeah
what is it Jim Belushi oh right okay
yeah and Jim's are fantastic you know
because David is casting is just
impeccable
you know spot-on so everyone whatever
you know I feel
interesting experience first day on the
set you know handsome good-looking guy
comes up Caleb Jones and he's
well-mannered he's well behaved you know
he's charming man this has got to be the
next generation of Twin Peaks you know
this is cool I'm looking at the show and
he's freaking twisted deranged you know
not run out of his nose kind of like
what Harry Dean Stanton said about the
Harry Dean please call rod that trial
manager that truck trailer park
he said is a [ __ ] nightmare you know
we were giving the script so coming back
to Twin Peaks I didn't have any idea
what's happened it's kind of like Rip
Van Winkle head no I just what it is so
I see it for the first time I have no
idea it's kind of weird we haven't read
the script but you but you go trust
David yeah I understand I think you're
the one that's ready oh let me teach you
we don't know you I satin Riddler yeah
they told me that he had to read it
blindfolded entirely Deven thank you
right yeah all right now I sat for yeah
it was a five or six hour read a cup of
coffee couple cups of coffee
mm-hmm and when you finished your
initial reaction how many times did you
you say why what what do they explain
that I felt it felt very cohesive
actually I now have worked with David
for a number of years you know so I'm
you get a sense of executive right now
yeah I'd serve all in so but I I felt
the direction I was just thrilled
because it was he and Mark all the way
through Frost and knowing that David was
going to direct every scene of this was
the game change or anything I wanted
from the guys back what was it like me
what's it like being on a David Lynch
set intimidating I mean you feel like
you're racing with like legends yeah you
know so it's a little overwhelming but
it was good I mean it's rewarding it's
certainly it's nice to be in this
company yeah it's really uh as far as
working like that environment is so
comfortable okay when you're comfortable
it really helps them as actors to be
able to just you know be able to be free
and do it you can you know and you trust
him to guide you along no matter what it
is that he's bringing out you know as a
happier set I've ever been on yeah was
arleigh happy or just break the
perceptions people are just very
pleasant and having a good time the time
I saw no stress between people I never
saw any kind of aggravation and kind of
pettiness it was just a wonderful
feeling it's an ambience I do just enjoy
being we are even though the characters
are doing very bizarre bizarre things
we'd like to do something right no way
all right
just one little hint of what's to come
and is there something that will make
our minds or our heads kind of spin
around when we watch this yes yes yes
maybe I don't know nudee Alex no doubt
yeah no doubt have you seen episode 8 I
mean throw up in your head will turn
around
alright I gotta let you guys know or
they'll kill me but um thank you for
coming by on camera go enjoy Tomica by
the way is there anything you're looking
forward to here at comic-con
well I could tell you what I found out I
stepped out of the limo yesterday and
there was a five hundred screaming girls
racing right toward me oh yeah they were
honest I knew he does come up gonna be
fondly trampled to death
hey what getting all over my ass to get
to the Teen Wolf guys know that then
whoa man they're going crazy oh no no am
I glad lady Timo while these has playing
this uh or Guetta and they are and they
go crazy and that would be
I know a girl screaming last night that
Guy'd and going to him thank y'all thank
you thank you